I know you're excited to run the app.
And I'm going to show you how to do it
without a physical device,
because we'll be using the emulator.
But first, we need to install one more
component from the Android SDK Manager.
Click on this button to open up
the Android SDK Manager.
Scroll to the bottom
of the list to find HAXM.
It stands for hardware
accelerated execution manager.
And it will speed up our emulator.
So go ahead and deselect
the other packages,
and just install this one.
Accept the license, and then continue.
We have to do one more step
after this to install HAXM.
I'll show you the remaining steps
on a Mac, but for the other platforms
you can check the link below.
First, find Android Studio
under the applications folder,
and then hit show package contents.
Then, in the SDK folder,
there'll be an extras folder
containing an Intel folder
with the HAXM folder.
Then, we click on the DMG file,
open it up and then continue.
Step through this installer,
and the default values are fine.
Once installation is complete,
you can close all the windows.